Hey, what's up everyone? I'm at the
airport.
Finally
leaving this crap hole city called
Austin. Just wanted to send out a thanks
to everyone who contributed to our
books for
broke nerds
fundraiser.
People gave way beyond
what I asked. I asked for 500 bucks for
each of four guys. People gave way
beyond that and so ended up buying a ton
of books for a bunch of different
people. I was basically just saying,
"Hey, you want some books? Hey, you want
some books? Hey, grab those books."
And people got a bunch of them. I did
see someone
asked to see what kind of books the guys
are buying and so on. Um, I'm already at
the airport, but right before we left I
got Anthony to
pose for a picture with his haul. So,
this is Anthony's haul.
He insists he will read all of these
books. So, anyway, you guys ended up
making a lot of nerds very happy. I'm
going to get home, check out all the
receipts, see how much I spent. There
There's going to be a bunch left over,
so I'm just going to divide it up among
all those guys and they can have some
money for whatever they want or for more
books. Anyway, thanks, guys.